(Flüstert:)
Pst! Gut, dass du da bist.
Setz dich, mach's dir gemütlich.
Hol dir deine Kopfhörer,
wir kitzeln
jetzt ein bisschen unsere Gehirne.
Freunde der Sonne, falls ihr euch
gerade fragt, warum ich flüstere,
dann habt ihr wahrscheinlich
noch nicht von ASMR gehört.
ASMR steht für:
Und es gibt ein ganzes Genre
auf YouTube mit ASMR-Videos.
Menschen gucken sich
diese ASMR-Videos gerne an,
weil sie dabei
ein wohlig kitzelndes,
fast schon
elektrisierendes Gefühl verspüren,
zunächst im Kopf,
im Schädel-Nacken-Bereich.
Das kann dann runtergehen
bis zu den Schultern
oder bis in den Rücken und die Arme.
Wie kann es überhaupt sein,
dass leise Geräusche solche
körperlichen Gefühle auszulösen?
Das werden wir uns heute
wissenschaftlich anschauen.
Fangen wir erst mal damit an,
wie viele Menschen
überhaupt ASMR erleben können.
Dazu gibt es leider
noch keine umfassenden Studien.
Ich hab bisher auch
nur eine kleine Umfrage gefunden.
91 Menschen wurden befragt.
Mehr als die Hälfte gab an, dass
sie ASMR erleben, fühlen können.
Wir können hier
zur Aufklärung beitragen.
Stimmt hier oben ab,
wie es bei euch aussieht.
Ich bin mir sicher, wir kriegen
mehr als 91 Leute zusammen.
Ich selbst spüre überhaupt nichts,
wenn ich solche ASMR-Videos sehe.
Für mich ist es alles reine Theorie,
deswegen freue ich mich dieses Mal
besonders auf eure Kommentare.
Und bitte, falls ihr ASMR
erleben könnt, spüren könnt,
schreibt mir ausführlicher,
wie sich das anfühlt.
Jedenfalls, dank YouTube,
wurde ASMR so bekannt,
dass irgendwann sogar die
Wissenschaft darauf aufmerksam wurde.
Ich meine, schaut euch mal
diese wissenschaftliche
Veröffentlichung an.
Hier ist ungelogen eine Tabelle
mit YouTube-Kanälen drin.
Ich mein,
wie geil ist das denn bitte?
Dieses Paper
ist übrigens eines der wenigen,
die das Phänomen
wissenschaftlich untersuchen
und nicht nur beschreiben.
Dazu haben sie
einige 100 Leute befragt,
die nach eigenen Angaben ASMR haben.
Den Fragebogen der Studie
verlinke ich euch unten.
Den könnt ihr euch mal anschauen,
falls ihr euch dafür interessiert.
Laut dieser Studie sind folgendes
die Haupttrigger, die ASMR auslösen:
Nummer 1: Flüstern.
Nummer 2:
persönliche Aufmerksamkeit.
Oft wird
das ASMR-Erlebnis besonders gut,
wenn es mit Rollenspielen
gepaart ist.
Sehr beliebt sind:
ein Friseurbesuch.
Oder auch,
seltsamerweise, ein Arztbesuch.
Nummer 3: klare, knackige Töne.
Deshalb werden auch gerne diverse
Haushaltsgegenstände benutzt,
um ASMR zu triggern.
Oh, war das jetzt zu laut? Sorry.
Oder ist das gut? Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich hier mache.
Und interessanterweise
erleben Menschen dieselben Gefühle
nicht nur durch Geräusche,
sondern auch zum Beispiel
durch visuelle Reize.
Ganz oben mit dabei ist:
Jemand anderen dabei zu beobachten,
wie er oder sie
etwas malt oder zeichnet.
Kennt ihr Bob Ross?
Bob Ross muss
der ultimative ASMR-Kick sein.
Maybe there is some happy low trees,
right here, right there.
Let them go. Let them go.
Und auch haptische Reize können
ASMR angeblich auszulösen.
Darunter: Haare anfassen,
sowohl die Haare von jemand anderem
als auch die eigenen Haare.
Oder auch jemand anderem Make-up
oder Nagellack auftragen.
What the fuck.
Frage an alle ASMRler da draußen:
Was sind eure Lieblingstrigger?
Und findet ihr,
ist das jetzt ein gutes ASMR-Video
oder könnt ich
irgendetwas besser machen?
Ich kann es nicht beurteilen, weil
ich verspüre es wie gesagt nicht.
Die Studie untersuchte außerdem,
ob ASMR vielleicht
gegen Depressionen helfen könnte.
Bei Teilnehmern mit Depressionen gab
es einen deutlichen Stimmungsanstieg
beim Schauen solcher ASMR-Videos.
Und diese erhöhte Stimmung hielt auch
ein paar Stunden danach noch an.
Interessant ist auch:
Je stärker die Depression,
desto höher der Stimmungssprung.
Fast alle gaben an, dass sie
ASMR sehr entspannend finden.
Viele gaben an, dass sie ASMR
gerne zum Einschlafen schauen.
Könnt ihr ja mal ausprobieren
mit diesem Video,
so weird das Ganze ist,
vor allem für mich.
Ist es eher unwahrscheinlich,
dass ASMR eine Art
sexueller Fetisch ist,
was manche zwar vermuten,
aber das empfinden die Wenigsten so.
So interessant diese Studie auch ist,
beruhen die Daten nur auf Fragebögen
und auf eigenen Aussagen
der Teilnehmer.
Wenn man das jetzt
sorgfältiger untersuchen wollte,
muss man
ein paar Schritte weitergehen.
Ich hab hier ne Studie gefunden,
wo Hirnscans gemacht wurden.
Die Leute, die ASMR erleben,
wurden verglichen mit Leuten wie mir,
die keine ASMR erleben.
Und dabei kam raus, dass bei ASMRler
manche Gehirnregionen
stärker miteinander verknüpft sind
und andere dafür weniger stark.
Daraus kann man jetzt
allerdings noch nicht wirklich
viel praktische Konsequenzen ziehen.
Vor allem weil diese Studie
unglaublich klein sind.
Es waren nur jeweils
elf Teilnehmer pro Gruppe.
Man vermutet aber, dass
die sensorischen Hirnregionen,
also die Teile des Gehirns, die für
Sinneswahrnehmungen zuständig sind,
bei ASMRlern
generell stärker verknüpft sind.
ASMR wird oft
mit Synästhesie verglichen.
Das ist
ein ähnlich abgefahrenes Phänomen,
wo Menschen zum Beispiel Töne sehen.
Wo Menschen z.B. mit verschiedenen
Tönen verschiedene Farben verbinden,
verschiedene Farben sehen.
Abgesehen davon, dass ASMR
ein seltsamer Internettrend ist,
könnte es ernsthaft Potenzial haben
als therapeutisches Mittel
gegen Depressionen,
vielleicht auch gegen Angstzustände.
Aber dafür muss ASMR erst mal
ein bisschen näher untersucht werden.
Wie gesagt, falls ihr ASMR verspürt,
würde es mich sehr interessieren,
was zum Teufel mit euch los ist?
Und in der Endcard empfange ich euch
zu einem exklusiven Friseurtermin.
Untertitel:
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk (2018)
Herzlich willkommen
bei deinem Friseurtermin.
Wie macht man das jetzt? Eigentlich
müsste ich so machen, oder?
Aber dann hört man es nicht so gut.
Okay, ich schneide jetzt seine Haare.
Währenddessen kann ich dir
den latest Gossip erzählen.
MaiLab wurde für
den Grimme-Online-Award nominiert.
Und es gibt einen Publikumspreis.
Falls du mich unterstützen willst,
als Dankeschön dafür,
dass ich dir die Haare schneide,
dann kannst du in den Link
in der Videobeschreibung schauen.
Ich geb dir als Gegenleistung
auch noch ein paar extra
Close-up-Scherenschnitte.
Ist das gut?